sie sind viel zu früh auf die welt
gekommenen babys geboren in einen krieg
ihre mütter oft traumatisiert von
bombenangriffen und einem leben auf der
flucht verängstigt warten einige im flur
mit uns reden möchten sie nicht
krankenpfleger mehmert weiß viele babys
werden es nicht schaffen und auch die
die sie retten sind längst nicht in
sicherheit
wir brauchen hier endlich eine
waffenruhe
dann könnten sie in ihr eigenes zuhause
zurück und die familien könnten wieder
selbst für sich sorgen
damit ist drei tage alt seine eltern
kommen aus aleppo vertriebene die in
idlib schutz suchen nach einer schweren
geburt bei der auch seine lunge
gequetscht wurde muss halt erst einmal
in der klinik bleiben
das leiden wird beginnen wenn sie hier
herauskommen sie gehen dann an orte wo
es keine heizung kein essen keine
geborgenheit und keinen schutz gibt doch
auch hier ist es nicht sicher minute und
seine kollegen haben angst dass ihre
klinik zum ziel von bombenangriffen
werden könnte vor allem während wir hier
sind
wir fahren weiter durch idlib die letzte
region die noch von aufständischen gegen
das assad-regime gehalten wird einen tag
lang können wir filmen und uns frei
bewegen allerdings dürfen wir keine
kämpfer und keine checkpoints zeigen
darauf achten unsere begleiter solche
situationen begegnen uns immer wieder
familien die ihre kinder auf anblick
abgeladen haben und auf den straßen
unterwegs sind unser begleiter erklärt
das so dass er sagt die leute versuchen
einfach irgendwo eine unterkunft zu
finden auf der flucht wo auch immer
platz ist campieren menschen längst gibt
es nicht mehr genug zelte in den
flüchtlingslagern fehlt es an sauberem
wasser essen und warmen decken
schätzungsweise eine million menschen
drängen sich in idlib eingekesselt
zwischen ersatz vorrücken der armee und
der türkischen grenze dieser 2015 für
syrer geschlossen ist ich erlebe kinder
die nichts anderes kennen als flucht und
krieg die viel zu früh erfahren haben
wie hunger und kälte sich anfühlen
bis mai zeigt uns wie sie die milch für
ihre sechs monate alte schwester
vorbereitet ihre mutter ist zehn tage
nach der geburt gestorben
seitdem versorgt die neunjährige das
baby auf meine frage ob sie ihn und für
ihre geschwister sorgen muss nickt sie
nur bis mai und ihre schwester bringen
kein wort heraus es sind die mädchen die
die ganze verantwortung für den haushalt
tragen viel zu früh ist mein kümmert
sich um ihre schwestern und ihren bruder
sie macht milch für sie füttert sie denn
ich habe nicht das geld zu heiraten und
für sie eine mutter zu bekommen
in den dicht gedrängten straßen von
samana einer kleinstadt direkt an der
grenze zur türkei herrscht eine
aggressive angespannte stimmung die
frauen sind fast
streng verschleiert hier kontrollieren
die dschihadistischen milizen der heirat
tachira und andere von der türkei
unterstützte rebellengruppe ich falle
hierauf auch in mantel und kopftuch
während wir ein interview führen werden
wir umringt von männern die meisten sind
nur neugierig doch dann tauchen
plötzlich bewaffnete kämpfer auf wollen
wissen was wir tun
eine beängstigende situation unsere
begleiter können sie beschwichtigen wir
beschließen zu gehen
wir fahren nach marc mees riem hier ist
eine bombe direkt auf dem schulhof
eingeschlagen die spuren ziehen sich
über das ganze gebäude
es ist gerade einmal 14 tage her da
wurde die schule getroffen das war an
einem nachmittag fünf kinder sind dabei
ums leben gekommen
die kinder die jetzt hier noch sind
haben keinen schulunterricht mehr und
sie sagen uns dass sie große angst davor
haben wir noch weitere angriffe zu
erleben
die jungen waren dabei als es passierte
meine schwester lief dort über den
schulhof als das flugzeug angriff
passierte nichts aber ein ast fiel auf
sie sie hatte verletzungen am bein und
hier und hier
schwer verletzt hat ahmad schwester über
liebt die jungen wollen mit den
klassenraum zeigen hier saßen sie als
die bombe fiel die schule ist jetzt
geschlossen sie sind den ganzen tag über
auf der straße sich selbst überlassen
viele von ihnen wurden mit ihren
familien schon mehrfach vertrieben
ich habe keine zukunft ich bin 14 und
kann gerade mal ein paar buchstaben auch
das sind szenen die wir auf unserer
fahrt erleben mitglieder der weiß helme
eine inzwischen weltbekannte syrische
zivilschutzorganisation versuchen ein
bisschen abwechslung in den alltag der
kinder in den flüchtlingslagern zu
bringen
doch der schmerz schwingt immer mit fast
eine halbe millionen kinder
so schätzen es internationale
organisationen sitzen zurzeit in den
lagern von idleb fest mehr als die
hälfte sind nach un-angaben mit ihren
familien bereits mehrfach vertrieben
wurden
die kinder würden aus ihren städten
verjagt die städte in denen sie
aufgewachsen sind an diese schöne
erinnerungen haben
dann fehlten sie sich auf einmal in
einem krieg ohne schutz wie lange noch
werden sie hier sicher sein dass fragen
sie sich in den flüchtlingslagern und in
den zelten am straßenrand und uns fragen
sie warum schaut die weltgemeinschaft
einfach zu eine frage die wir mitnehmen
von einer reise die uns einen einblick
gegeben hat in die tragödie von idlib